all right people it is monday october 26
2020. we are eight days
from the election from the day that will
decide the fate of humanity
eight freaking days people here we go
all right i normally don't do direct
messages
on mondays and fridays however i'm doing
a mini one right now then we're going to
do our regular shows tuesday wednesday
thursday and then we're going to do
another one on friday because obviously
this week
is going to be as i like to say bananas
it's going to be ultra bananas this week
obviously
and then i can only imagine what's going
to happen into the weekend and monday
and tuesday and then once the
election results aren't accepted then
you know the next couple years and all
that but we'll one thing at a time let's
just deal with today as it is
so i'm doing just a quick show today
where i'm just going to show you two
clips
uh that the mainstream media won't show
you you are obviously not
going to see these on cnn you're not
going to see them on abc nbc cbs or
anywhere else
but these are on fire online and when i
talk about
the reality war the fact that whether
you watch
online stuff or mainstream stuff and
which online stuff and mainstream stuff
you watch
you live in an actually different
reality at this point
than people who consume other things i
think that if you're watching this your
reality is somewhat similar to mine and
i think we've got a pretty decent grasp
on reality over here
but but even even i'm gonna have my
blind spots but i thought that these two
clips
which are so indicative of something
that's happening right now that the
mainstream won't talk about
were important to show so this first
clip that we're going to throw to
this is uh joe biden forgetting who he's
running against
this is the most consequent not because
i'm running but because who i'm running
against it's the most consequential
election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he is going to find ourselves in
a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
and uh and so all right glibness
and sarcasm and humor aside
um i feel bad for the sign language lady
because what was she supposed to do in
the middle of that all right that wasn't
glibness aside
um this is seriously depressing joe
biden has
obviously the early onset early stages
of dementia
and not only is nobody saying anything
about it they're actively using him and
go back rewind the clip for 20 seconds
from now
and watch jill biden she mouths trump
twice to him
she she this is elder abuse i mean she
is abusing her husband and using him to
attain power that's what all of the dnc
people are
that's what everyone who's supporting
joe biden doing they are
they are using this person who obviously
is not capable who has
serious cognitive issues that it's
miraculous yes i know what a bunch you
are going to say especially if you're
more mainstream media type people
you're going to say oh but during the
debates he seems lucid he seems
cognizant yes that's right they put him
somewhere for four days they shut him
down i don't know if he's sleeping the
entire time and then they
have him snort some adderall or god
knows what they're doing
something is not right and you only see
it if you pay attention
to the news online and and for now our
ability to trade clips on youtube and
twitter and everywhere else but who
knows how much longer
we'll have that ability it's just i
thought it was important to show that
because this isn't just like some little
verbal gaffe we all make verbal gaffes
i speak live to a camera all the time
i'm going to screw up a word here and
there
you're going to screw up a date or get
you know forget something all of those
things like all of that is totally legit
the man running for president literally
could not remember
the name of his opponent who happens to
be the current president of the united
states okay
that is a problem but you're not going
to see it on cnn and you're not going to
see it anywhere else and
and i thought it was just worth just
there it is there it's for you to decide
don't even listen to anything i'm saying
about it
does that seem right to you yes or no i
guess that's the real question
and then there was another clip going
making the rounds this weekend another
one abide in
and by the way before i even play this
one i should say that's not to say trump
doesn't say some funny things and
odd things and he has a strange way you
know he starts talking then he
interrupts himself and then he kind of
gets back and reverses him
because he's doing a lot of stream of
conscious stuff um which
you know that that's fine that's partly
what i do here right like i don't really
write much down i scribble down a few
things before we start and then i just
talk to you and sometimes
you got a lot of thoughts in your head
and you want to get to them and and all
that and i find that also as an
interviewer
that's actually kind of fun when you see
a guest who's really off
off the cuff who's really exploring the
stuff with you because they're not going
into pre-packaged
things but when you're truly off the
cuff you might be a little more prone to
mistakes and things like that that
that's okay right or you might be a
little more prone to
to forgetting what you're saying so
there were times one more thing then
i'll get to this biden clip
there were times when i was on tour with
uh jordan peterson and i would moderate
the q
a at the end so we do about 45 minutes
of q a this is after he's given
an hour and a half lecture we've
traveled that day he's done a ton of
interviews blah blah
and at the end i'd be asking questions
that were from the crowd usually i'd
pepper in some of my own questions
and he'd go on a long long tangent on
somebody else's question and it's like
12 minutes later and i'm trying to
listen to him
so that i can then you know twist it
into some other place that might be
interesting right
give it a little turn that might be
interesting for the crowd and then
sometimes he would say
so what was the question and i'd go i'm
not even sure and i'd have the audience
yell it again because if you're actually
trying to listen you might
you might sort of forget some of this
stuff okay that's a total sidebar
this next clip this is just from the
last couple days and
uh did biden just admit something that
we've all long suspected
let's find out secondly we're in a
situation where
we have put together and you guys
did it for our administ the president
obama's administration
before this we have put together i think
the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
all right so let me just repeat that for
you
uh i'm gonna just cut that obama part
because that was a little
sidebar there we have put together i
think
the most extensive and inclusive voter
fraud organization
in the history of american politics
now i don't think he meant to say that
obviously i don't think he's admitting
to a voting fraud organization
maybe there is a voting fraud
organization and maybe it has something
to do with the dnc but i don't even
think he would know about that but i'm
not even going conspiracy level here the
point
is that he said voter fraud organization
and he didn't even know that he said it
he might have meant to say voter
registration organization or some
other thing like that but it's the
general confusion the stammering
all of that stuff it's something it's
not
nothing i my grandma had dementia and
when i was doing stand-up in new york i
was usually working at night so i had
some of my days free and for about a
year i went often several times a week
to the doctor
with her to various doctors actually and
i know what that's like the confusion
the repetition sometimes the anger
all of those things i'm not doing this
again to be glib
or or nonsensical or whatever but the
point is
if your friends are voting for biden
your family members are voting for biden
and they don't see this stuff like the
simple truth is you're voting for kamala
harris or whatever the machine is behind
her
and let's not forget just you know what
was it two weeks ago
pelosi was talking about the 25th
amendment i mean that will be the plan
to get rid of an
incapacitated incapacitated
joe biden like that is that is it this
if he wins he's going to go in a bunker
they'll release statements every now and
again and try to get him out there
you know just in the the bare minimum
and then and then they'll just get rid
of him
and and jill biden should be embarrassed
and
and everyone behind this whole thing um
it's just it's just painful anyway i had
to show you those two things because
otherwise they don't get
c they don't get seen by people and then
the reality war as i'm always talking
about
just gets ramped up even more so maybe
share that with somebody
that that's on the fence and i don't
know they can they can make their own
decision all right people
we got tuesday wednesday thursday shows
this week then we're going to do a bonus
show
on friday we may even do stuff over the
weekend because obviously a lot's going
to happen this week
get out there as you can see it's a
little cool in los angeles today i'm
wearing a flannel for the first time and
god knows how long
uh get out there get some fresh air take
a walk don't go crazy
more tomorrow